اكدت قياده عمليات الجنوب في القوات
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا وضعت خمسه عشره سفينه
في مهمه قتاليه في البحر الاسود وقد شككت
في الوقت ذاته في ان تكون القوات الروسيه
قد تمكنت من اعاده تجهيز السفن بصواريخ
كاليبر بشكل كامل بعد الانفجارات التي
وقعت في شمال شبه جزيره القرم
مجموعه سفن العدو قويه جدا فقد وضعت خمسه
عشره سفينه في مهمه قتاليه في البحر
الاسود بما في ذلك ثلاث حاملات صواريخ
وغواصه لقد عزز العدو وجود سفنه في البحر
الاسود ليبقينا في حاله تاهب دائمه ورغم
حقيقه ان بعض السفن قد لا تكون مجهزه
بالصواريخ فان الغواصه الروسيه قد تكون
مجهزه بصواريخ دقيقه وفي حاله التاهب
القتالي يبقى خطر الاستهداف الصاروخي من
البحر والجو وباستخدام طائرات مسيره